foreign
[Music]
okay so look
let me turn it on
correctly
you turn it on
internal
just bounding
then
as you
go I stay whoa
too too much all right go back into
great internal external
so go back
you see and then when I go to throw it's
going to be internally okay so it's not
just
get out of the way it's not gonna work
do you understand
who
oh
foreign
[Music]
cannot internalize
to use externalize it until you can
re-internalize but even as you go
external
internal in it like the yinyog symbol
you got it can't be completely external
or your performance envelope goes way
down like that one time okay so if
you're not sure what I'm talking about
I'm just going to move my shoulders up
get it and I'll let all of it wait till
I get there I'm going to let all the
external all the internal Dead all right
so over here
yeah it didn't actually work